- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is "believe",
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the major problems in the world.
So to help you on your journey
today we're want to talk
about how you can configure out
what you really, really want.
Rule number four is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below,
put quotes around it so that
other people can be inspired,
you might win a prize too.
And also when your write it down
it's much more likely to
stick to yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(gentle music)
(reflexive music)
- The point I want to share with you is,
when I was growing up my
dad took out this poem
and he translated it from
Sanskrit into English,
and it was a poem from the
Bengali poet Rabindranath Tagore.
And allow me to share it with you,
it's simply said,:
"Spring is past, summer has
gone and winter is here,
"and the song I meant
to sing remains unsung,
"for I've spent my days stringing
"and unstringing my instrument".
And my brother and I used
to look at it every morning
before we go out to school but
I never really understood it,
so when I got a little older I said,
"Dad, you know that poem you
had on our refrigerator door.
"What was it all about?"
And my dad looked at me and he said,
"Robin, that was a poem written by a man
"whose heart was filled with
regret over a life half-lived".
He said, "Robin, that was
a poem written by a man
"who postponed his life.
"He always wanted to do something special.
"He always wanted to do important work.
"He always wanted to
be loving in the world.
"He always wanted to be creative.
"He always wanted to see the world,
"but he got busy being busy".
Are you being busy being busy?
Have you lost that connection
to the life you wanted to live
when you were a little kid?
Are you so busy stringing your instrument
that the song that your
life was meant to sing
has died or is dormant within you?
And my challenge to you is simply this:
to do whatever it takes
before you sleep tonight
to reconnect with the best within you
that you may have lost.
Because one of the things
I've noticed is this,
there are too many amongst
us walking the planet today
who are sort in awakened sleep,
they have lost the sense
of who they truly are,
and your life will never
work if there's a huge space
between who you truly are
and the person you know
you're meant to be.
Your life will never
be flooded with energy,
creative, productivity and happiness
if there is a large space
between your life right now
and your unlived life.
And my request and encouragement
and challenge to you
is truly that you make things happen
so that the person you
are starting tomorrow
is more who you know you truly are.
It makes me thing of George Bernard Shaw,
who was asked on his deathbed,
"What would you do if you could
live your life over again?"
And he replied, after a long pause,
"I wish I could become the
person I know I was meant to be".
And I suggest to you, it's
never too late for you to become
the person you've always wanted to be.
But don't postpone it for next year,
don't postpone it for next month,
start being that person, that human being,
that creative force,
that business builder,
that mother or father, that athlete,
that humanitarian, that force of good
that you have always wanted
to be beginning right now.
(reflexive music)
- If you're familiar with my work you know
for the last 34 years
I've been just obsessed
with wanting to know
what makes the difference
in the quality of people's lives.
Why is it so many people have big dreams
but such a small number of people
ever make those dreams a reality?
And for those that do make it reality,
what is it to gets them
not only to follow through
but then to enjoy what they have?
I don't know if you've
ever had the experience
of achieving something
that you've always wanted
and then afterwards thinking to yourself,
"Is this all there is?"
It's one of the worst feelings, the worst.
It's almost worst than failing,
'cause when you fail at least you know,
"Heck, I can still find
a way to make it happen",
but when you succeed and you're not happy,
you're not fulfilled, then
you got a real problem.
There's two things that control
everything in your life,
every thought, every
feeling, every emotion,
every action you have in your life,
what you're wearing today,
whether you're going to turn
this off within a few minutes
or whether you're going to stick with me
for two or three minutes,
it's all controlled by two things:
your beliefs and your values.
Whatever you believe, if you think life
is just a waste of time,
doesn't matter what you do,
or you're big-boned, then, obviously,
you're not going to go forth,
you're not going to try to lose weight,
you're not going to go
push for that next level
with your career or your finances
or your relationship or anything else.
Beliefs control us, but so do our values.
Some people, you know,
value just kicking back,
some people value making it happen,
some people value their family the most,
some people value love.
But you know what the real challenge is?
When values are in conflict,
when you really want to make
a difference in the world
or you really want to do
wealth for your family,
or you really want to do well financially,
but simultaneously you
don't want to upset anybody,
you want to be totally honest
and you want to make everybody happy.
When we have conflicts
between what we want
and what we think we can have,
or you have a goal, what your
really want to make happen,
but then you have this other
belief inside that says,
"This damn stuff never does work".
Those inner conflicts are what keep people
from using all of their energy,
it's kind of like taking two steps forward
and three steps back.
You know, it used to be
people kind of run on
kind of seven-year cycles, it's
kind of an arbitrary number
but think about it, from 17 to 24
it's kind of stage a
life for a lot of people,
from 24 really to about 31,
that's another stage of life,
32 to 39 or 40 years old, another stage,
40 to 47, another stage.
And those are random
numbers, but what I mean is
people tend to have an idea of
what they think life's about,
"It's my kids. It's building my business".
"It's making money.
It's God. It's family".
Whatever it is, and then they go for it
for a period of time, three,
four, five, six, seven years,
whatever, maybe 10,
but then there's a time
in which people begin to question,
they begin to look at their
life and they begin to say,
"Is this really what I want?"
Have you found yourself at that any time?
And then they do one of two things,
they either recommit and they
go for another seven years
and they take it to another level,
or they make a strategic decision
that shifts the direction of their life.
Either way, your decision
control your destiny,
and if you don't choose,
that's a choice as well.
Some people just kind
of stay in the middle,
in that lukewarm place, not
sure what they really want.
So, this is kind of off the cuff,
what I'm really trying to say to you is,
maybe the question to ask is,
"What I want my life to be today,
"and where am I really going?
"What is my destiny?
What's going to fill me up?
"What's going to give me
the meaning for my life?
"What's going to give me joy in my life,
"not just achievement but real enjoyment,
"a sense of meaning and aliveness?"
- Seven billion plus people on the planet,
you're different than
every single one of them.
There's a unique aspect
to your personality,
your style, your intentions,
your actions, your habits,
your beliefs, who you are,
and the way that you think is
unique from everybody else.
We can measure it by science,
we can measure it by observation,
we can measure it just by simply
asking people basic questions to discover
everyone's got their own opinion,
everyone's got their own world view.
And because of that then we have to ask,
"Well, am I living my life uniquely?
"Am I expressing who I genuinely am?
"Are my expression genuine
and authentic and spontaneous
"to who I am as a person,
or am I living a facade?
"Am I trying to be somebody
else to please somebody else,
"to gain acceptance or love over here,
"or am I truly being true to
myself, to my unique self,
"to the inner side of who I really am
"and what I want to show to the world?"
Because a lot of people
really struggle with this,
and the reason they start setting out
to look for their purpose in their life is
one day they wake up and they realize
they're not living their life,
they're living their parents' life,
their professor's life,
their teacher's life.
They're living the life their
society or their culture
or the norms told them to live.
One day they wake up and say, "Whoa!
"Why have I conformed to the point
"where I don't eve know who I am anymore?"
And they start this journey, sometimes,
to look for life's purpose
'cause they're trying to find themselves.
They're not looking for a big purpose,
they're looking for themselves.
And sometimes when we can tap back
into that uniqueness of who we are,
then the magic of life
comes alive again, you know?
That requires us to not only
exude who you are to the world
but to genuinely express
who we are, what we think,
what we desire of life, what we need.
How we truly feel and think
about the people in our lives,
the things that we are
doing with our lives,
the places and directions we're going.
We have to do that if we want to sense
that full uniqueness of ourselves.
And, often, it is by suppressing ourselves
that we begin to suffer,
and we have to again ask,
"Well, then, what is the
point of all of this?
"Is it to live as a carbon
copy of everybody else,
"or to fully, with full
intention and aliveness,
"animate the best of
who you are uniquely?"
I think that you being
yourself is the grand purpose.
- A brain tattoo I love sharing
with my audience is this one:
"A job is only just a job
if you see it as a job".
And so, why would you lose the opportunity
to leverage what you do
everyday to grow your happiness,
to grow your energy,
to allow you to release more
of your talents in the world,
to allow you to help more people?
Why would you miss that opportunity
by falling into the trap
of thinking, "This is just my job.
"I'm just getting up in the
morning, working nine to five,
"going down to the coal mine every day"?
And you could say, "Well, Robin,
"this doesn't apply to me.
"I just have an ordinary job".
Well, I've got to tell
you, I've met taxi drivers
who feel their work is
incredibly meaningful.
I mean I was at LaGuardia and I remember
being in a taxi cab, and the
man had this white shirt,
and his cab was perfection,
and I said, you know,
"Your attitude is great,
your passion is awesome,
"your cab is perfect,
"you've got this fresh
newspaper for me to read.
"What is your psychology
that allows you to do this?"
And he said, "Robin,
this is not a dirty job,
"it's an important job.
"I get to make a difference".
I remember being in
Johannesburg meeting the janitor
in the Johannesburg men's room or WC
who worked like he was the
Elon Musk of what he did.
He worked like Pavarotti sang.
And so my point is simply this,
it's really your choice
as to how you will view
the work you do every day,
and even in the most, quote,
unquote, "ordinary work"
you could find gold.
And if you connect with the gold,
you connect with the meaning.
And if you connect with the meaning,
you connect with your talent.
And if you connect with your talent,
you connect with the best within you.
And if you connect with
the best within you,
you go to work every day
and you are this shining
star of world-class,
and you become the
Picasso of your industry,
and everything else takes care of itself.
- I just can't explain
to everybody, like, clear
when you figure out who you
are and do all that, you win.
If you're great at painting, paint,
and hire a partner to be your salesperson.
If somebody at 20 years old made me
their business partner as a painter,
they'd be the most famous
painter in the world.
Yet, most painters want to be the salesman
and businessman, and women,
as well as the painter,
and there's a problem.
80% of painting, 90% of people
that are great at painting
are artists, and don't
have the DNA to sale.
And vice versa, all my sales
friends or business friends
that want to start all these businesses
around something creative,
I've bad news for you, joll,
you know, you can be a great salesman
but your pottery sucks (muted).
And so that's that.
So, like, and that's a very
funny analogy for the following:
figure out who you are, don't
apologize for who you are,
and then become even greater
than you naturally are
at what you are.
- [Man In Phone] I think too
many people give a (muted)
what other people think
about them as well.
- Well, that's the whole ...
The whole game's broken, because everybody
is too tied up into
other people's opinions.
I only care about my opinion of myself.
And I care what my mom and wife and kids
and the world think, just
not as much as I care
about the way I think about myself.
And that's it, just that slight advantage.
And I think most of you care more about
what other people think than
what you think about yourself
and/or you actually don't feel
good about yourself, right?
The thing that made me smile,
when you just introduced me you said
I'm one of the most motivational
people in the world, comma,
"and everybody I know that's met him
"said he's the nicest guy".
There's no comparison
to the better feeling
of people that have actually
got to know me say that
versus millions, hundreds of thousands,
tens of thousands
thinking I'm the coolest.
And that's it. I mean, that's it.
And that's why, and that's
why it's easy for me
to feel good about myself, right?
And so, I think a lot of people
need to start with themselves.
Maybe the reason they
don't have more confidence
in themselves or care about
their opinion about themselves
versus others is 'cause they know
they're doing things they don't like,
so they need to work on that.
I get offered in email 5,000 different
requests for podcasts and shows,
and what I think my friend here,
let's see his name, Evan, Bo ...
Bo, let's send it in ...
Bo. I'm sorry, Evan Carmichael
introduced me to Bo.
What Bo has figured out
is time is the asset,
and so if you want Kevin Hart or The Rock
or Beyonce or Ja Rule
or Richard Branson or Tony Hsieh
or Charles Samberg on your podcast,
maybe you should start
a 120-second podcast,
and then you got to be
creative and try to figure out
how you get --
Maybe you create the "One
Question" video show.
That's it, whole show is one question.
Promise you, a lot of people
that you want as guest,
if they see in the headline,
"I just need four minutes of your time
"for the 'One Question' show",
a lot more are going to say yes than,
"Can you be on my podcast
for an hour and a half?"
- How do you know when
you are on the right path,
and what dream belongs to you,
or what husband belongs to you,
or what job belongs to you?
- You know you're on the
right path, here's your clue,
you're not put in a
position to betray yourself.
You don't betray yourself anymore.
You don't, you're not put in the position
where you feel like you have to negotiate
your sense of integrity,
which is an act of betrayal,
your heart, an act of betrayal.
You don't feel like you have
to compromise who you are.
It feels right.
- You can fully, I got that,
it's like if you had a job,
you know you're really
gifted and talented,
people are not paying you for
what you value yourself to be,
you're coming to work
everyday feeling like
"I'm really not valued.
"I'm not being respected for what I do",
or "My boss is unkind", or
whatever the situation might be.
There is an unease with you.
- That's right.
- Yeah.
And so, when you have
more respect for yourself,
put yourself in a position where you can
feel your sense of value or worth.
- Right.
- That turned around.
- That's right.
- And that's how you know?
- You know. You know
because you don't feel like,
"This isn't costing me my power.
"This isn't costing me my psyche.
"This isn't costing me my soul".
- Okay, this is really good.
- "This isn't costing me my sense of ...
"I don't feel confused in some deep level.
"I'm not drained.
"I can be tired after a day's work,
"but I'm not psychically drained
"where I feel like I'm losing life".
- "And losing myself".
- That's what a lot of people say,
"I'm losing myself".
- "I'm losing myself".
Why? Because I'm betraying
myself in some way.
- What is the difference?
Because I have a lot of married friends,
I have interviewed a lot of people
during the years who are married,
and everybody talks about how difficult,
how, you know, it's work,
"a relationship is work,
it's work, it's work".
What is the difference
between betraying yourself
and compromising?
Because that's what you
have to do to get along.
- I'd say that a compromise,
compromise is when you
willingly, willingly ...
- Willingly.
- Willingly, and out of love.
Saying, "That's, alright, a
little this, a little that.
"Little this, little that".
But in a compromise you don't go away
feeling like "I've betrayed myself.
"I've betrayed myself.
"I've allowed myself, I've
put poison in my mouth here".
- Okay, it goes back to
exactly what you said earlier
that every choice is either
going to enhance your spirit
or it's going to drain your spirit.
So, if you have been
compromised to the point
where you feel drained or depleted ...
- Right.
- Then you've betrayed yourself.
- You have, I mean,
and the number of times
someone will say to themselves,
"I want to get out of this circumstance
"but I'm too afraid to
take care of myself,
"so I will lie about how
happy I am in this marriage,
"I will put up a front,
I will lie about this",
but they're betraying everything
that's in their heart.
They're betraying everything.
When they say to me, "Am
I on the right path?",
here's what's true,
you're on your right path,
you're just not managing
it that well right now.
- You're never on the wrong path?
- You're never on the wrong path,
you're just not managing it well.
You're making choices that are harming you
and that's why it's hurting right now.
You're making unwise choices,
and your intuition is
trying to tell you --
- You're making unwise choices,
including the path that
you're on right now.
- And the way you're
managing the path you're on,
and it's harming you.
- Okay.
- And when your life
path begins to harm you,
then we have to sit back and
say, "You've taken a detour".
- You know, I just had an
"A-ha!" listening to you.
I love it when that happens to me.
I've often thought that,
and it's because of your
use of the word "betrayal",
I've often thought having
experience being betrayed
by a close member of my
family years ago, thinking,
"That was the worst",
that there's nothing
worse than being betrayed.
And just hearing you talk about it today,
I think there's nothing worst
than betraying yourself,
that the worst, most ultimate betrayal
is the betrayal to yourself.
- You're right.
- Yeah.
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
your think of this video?
What did you take from
it that you're going
to immediately apply to your life
or to your business, somehow?
Please share, leave it
down the comments below,
I'm really excited to
see what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Skip Prichard.
Skip, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word", and doing
a review in your website,
as well as posting it to Twitter.
Thank you so much for the support, man,
and I'm really happy
that you enjoyed my book.
Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourselves.
And wherever, your one word is ...
Much love, have an amazing
day, and I'll see you soon.
- I wake up every single morning
with a very clear sense of purpose:
it's to inspire people
to do what inspires them
so together we can change our world.
And I have a very clear vision
of the world I want to live in:
I would like to live in a world
in which the vast majority of people
wake up every single morning
inspired to go to work,
they feel safe when they're there,
and they come home at the end of the day
fulfilled by the work that they do.
And I've committed all of my work,
and it doesn't matter what form it takes,
whether speaking or writing
or teaching or advising,
it doesn't even matter what form it takes,
in some way, shape or form
to help advance that vision
and move close and closer to it.
- The whole "What do I do
with my life?" question
implies that adulthood is
this monolithic creature
that like you acquire
your job and your spouse
and then you just write it out
until times winged chariot shows up.
I thought this when I was younger too,
and it's not our fault because,
how does every single
happily-ever-after movie end?
With finding your one true
love and kissing them,
occasionally marrying them,
at the very latest
having a child with them.
95% of romantic stories end with partners
committing to each other
because everything after that
is just a bleak, terrifying
morass of adulthood,
this monotonous grind,
in which the only real
excitement in your life
is occasionally finding
a truly right avocado
at the grocery store.
Now, listen, I'm not going to lie to you,
I get very excited when I find
the truly right avocado
at the grocery store,
but it's not the only
excitement in my life.
And that to me is that one of the reasons
you're so terrified about figuring out
what you're going to do with your life
is that your think that
you're only going to be able
to do one thing.
Like, if someone told
you that in four years
you were going to have to pick
one musical note to listen
to for the rest of your life
you would spend a lot of
time being super anxious
about which note to pick,
and the various tonal
qualities of different notes.
But that's not what life is like,
you will always be figuring
out what to do with your life,
and you'll get to do
lots of different things,
and your decisions will
be unmade by circumstance,
like your wife gets a job in Kuala Lumpur
or you're staring at
the night sky one night
and decide you want to
get a PhD in Astrophysics,
or your uncle dies and there's no one
to take over his junkyard,
or your little brother starts
a freaking video conference.
Just like your life now,
adulthood will have all this tension
between ideals and practicality,
and you'll have to
balance competing desires,
and you don't have to do just one thing,
you can be an Electrical Engineer
who volunteers on archeological digs.
William Carlos Williams was
both a poet and a doctor.
Julia Child, besides from
being an extraordinary chef
was also a freaking spy
for the United States.
I mean, heck, if you told my college self
that I'd one day be a
novelist with a side gig
of putting my mustachio face
on the torsos of strangers,
I would have been dully surprised.
And you studied organic fracking chemistry
before writing songs about Harry Potter.
So here is my advise: study
broadly and without fear,
learn a language, if you can,
because that will make
your life more interesting,
read a little bit everyday,
but, most importantly,
try to surround yourself
with people you like and
make cool stuff with them.
In the end, at least in my experience,
what you do isn't going to be
nearly as interesting or
important as who you do it with.
- A lot of people ask me,
"How do I know what my true purpose is?"
The answer is the difference
between a career and a calling.
It's the difference between
satisfaction and fulfillment.
It is the difference between
an interest and a passion.
What is the difference between
an interest and a passion?
So many people,
they're interested in
this, interested in that,
but, see, when you're
going to marry somebody
you don't get down on one knee and say,
"Baby, would you marry me?
I'm interested in you".
No, no, you don't do that
unless you want to get smacked
in the face and then left.
You got to say, "Baby,
I'm passionate about you.
"You complete me. I cannot
truly live this life
"without you, without us, together".
That's operating from the heart.
And if you don't operate from
the heart I can guarantee
you will live a life climbing a ladder,
and if you get to the top you will realize
that it was laying against the wrong wall.
They say, "Never become too
good at something you hate
"or they will make you do it
for the rest of your life".
So, look, ask yourself
these three questions:
What are your natural talents?
What is something you enjoy doing?
What is something that
you can't shut up about?
You got to read, write and talk about it.
That's how you get closer and closer
to your mission or purpose in life.
Still confused? Okay, so I
believe that the best teacher
of how to live life is death.
Legend has it that when
we're on our deathbed
we will be visited by ghosts,
these are the ghosts of our ideas, dreams,
abilities, talents given to us by life.
And if we never acted on that idea,
never pursued that dream,
never worked on those skills,
used our voice or wrote that book,
then those ghosts will
say, "We came to you,
"and only you could have given us life,
"but now we must die with you forever".
So, ask yourself this
question, my friends,
engage this thought experiment,
if you had one year to live, 365 days,
and whatever you chose to do
you were guaranteed to
succeed at, what would you do?
Chances all of that is what
you should be doing right now.